Tối nghe bây giờ tình sảo các quan phát thành trình yên ràn xanh nhận, chua sở cân yên rình tại Thủ Đô Thê Ràn,
là bị yên xerang không cất, trong lúc đang phát sống trình dự kép.
Video lan chuyên trình mạng sảo ở trở thấy,
và thành viên xa ai mà mi hộp phải dơ khỏi máy quay sau một tính nổ lớn,
khỏi vụ báo trung và anh tệ trường quay bụt tắt.
Yên xerang tuy mổ in nhất bốn quả bong là đánh trúng văn phòng chính trị của yên rình.
Cuối đối xerang cũng trường biến mục tiêu bị tân công là hạt tân và tài sản.
Bí ràn xử dụng trường bí quả nself, giới vỏ bỏ bỏ là dân xử.
Bốn trường cũng phòng xe xerang xe khả nè,
chến xe xe lực lượng phòng xe xerang thực gi yet và tuy mổ chứ đỏ xal tế nói của trình thông vi ràn xe biển mắt.
Còn ngày tê ra ra lệng xe tả, với 2 bánh trình hình Nm 2 bản nếu mình bốn quái xerang,
cảnh máu có cơ sở này có thể trở thành một tương công,
căng thẳng xe ai nước đăng lâu thăng nghiêm trọng,
với hàng chăm người thịnh mạng chi sâu vài ngày xao tranh.